My head back yesterday.
Today.
Parallax my heart for asking for a five day period.
Or a year or less or if I left a
day
or. You know.
I'm not going
to
do. And he has a lot of.
People
grandson. You can go on doing. That. The.
One after the.
Crew.
Know.
Them strong.
In
the right.
Who knew
him for years to.
The one who
I knew.
So.
Well for or to
cause this.
Well
on this site where people consider projects today
that there was a city. She saw him in person.
And the young person going to not vengeful I say you
can just go
on. But and do the one
for this in the
apartments on that same floor and you know the adults and talk to each other so as
to those organisms for the young to know young
pretty does I did the whole way. Goren
thing. You know good friends there were
a girl your boy she grew so fast they were
always around to always interact with defined again
John
through have your
organs or touch and
go.
To fund your fun for the project in
the game. You know
before it was a boy who people at all to actually interact and.
That is that it was soon to be I love my city are so
small and.
OK
Sue. Was describing that with a pull to do above.
In front of the building. You know they have to
walk through
about four feet and then there was a little drive through
through this war in the seventy's and the so this
isn't always right and we're very good. So we do
see the bases of the first one The first
is the second the thirty. This
tube is
on pretty much all created from nothing. Just have all the media will do this
for them over who couldn't walk off water for the morning to you know bore.
Jack to the table door from
Iran. No later than Saddam
or you want to hear it is so that it involves inside me and
I do feel pretty much
invisible and soon.
Well inside the saloon for
his honor and so on
but and then will go on in that
area for a five hour with said hello to the
the building. There's a stick up for
some crises for those
of us in the.
Oh it's understood has changed so much in time.
From the knowledge over there within
the hour which is not on and didn't is no longer
there and it's simply.
A pickoff flinches which is. It was of old age
and or
progress of the bill for.
Peace.
And didn't you know it evolves and changes.
Even though. We're Christians I ventured
know. And there was sort of riches
there was not credible data that we're used
to you know it all
happened I doubt saw the news of the people who. This is a
long story. So
listen in to that so
that
along. The whole
year for a very long. So.
The news in the restaurant is
the same Julien's does not.
Even today you will see the
song on.
One store on the.
Yeah
and also do Asians do it for
the creators in the restaurant and in the store.
Group of rubber. Well the out of the store
here comes and this is
why there is none of them on the crew.
Well series from the store less
the SO resonance and.
Yes.
And
that's
why. It was a
very well. I
guess she.
Can do it for the season.
See but.
To
see you know for a long time.
Or this is how much is is the
same which has changed so it's.
Oh
to be so all
the things that brightest
so grown up I was actually in
school. So there is just
something jumping the graduate into a job.
So the only one to good people in the community and
the help
of my resourceful.
Wow and positive work.
I don't know if he still have
so. She's going to quickly go to
college activities and.
Do. You know.
First you know you have to be all those who you.
Margaret are all rich and. Now
struggling to do the best in their group.
So after losing the this
is due
to the second. School
so he goes on.
Key which is probably the least expensive. We're going to have this.
Paid to do it so I had out of a job doing whatever bit and you
know during college I worked in well you know
a secure job just so he got an hour in the college and
college loans and pay off. So I'm doing
that. Do the work process called America.
And
so good so do that we're going to from
your physical
to say which of the following high school in
downtown Brooklyn his. Issues and the world
winds he noted all in the school did Y.M.C.A. he's in
town to work which is a new diseases
and a visual person with the horses and cars love. She's just and
just getting too hard to judge. The lack of you
want to do it over a
position. How's I work. And so I
did that and then the Sun King said we want the summer camp
over with. And the cost of doing
that
here comes on her which is
worse than this year for
her to show them.
This alliance. With the hundred something kids today
have we.
And yeah we saw it at the same gym program which is the
first and so I've really well in front of the sun care programs those
insurance committee. We took them on and at school program.
Is to run and. Since
all this is because I did what I had to do to
get the program so I think it was good for me because you know I'm
not the sort of I went to school to this
neighborhood. On this
in the fall
does the lack of preparation some fool.
Was that she says the situation in the community
and with the system as
a whole New York wrote a bunch who did
it coarsens and what happened in the end when it rolled out and how
all students
across the city did so that things. You know I
was proud of that so I can see the students will
come on and they're going to this is who
and this is a very good connections with this
school. Other
people and.
The Lebanese among others I have nothing
to do with
any of the
school but I'll
go is the desire to learn so
I can do a service and do
good work at GNC which is
the college cruise or
Greensboro area and then
have the University
of St Johns in other schools come
here to tell the difference and shooting or cause.
Cause not question. But it
will come to the wrong house to
a of those different schools in
some cases to the school didn't
elect for the school and we're here in D.C. or our
show is needed and this is all
that involved so. My mom goes to slide among those of
the See you need some of the your kids want something that you don't
know exists.
If you don't know
exactly what you do a fire is out
there so I feel confident and how
I can do that I can tell them about school do connect to the need
to know that for a long
and my school it with funding on bad
schools. So why would I want to go but a
college husband
in school activities like fancy
pants she sort of lost on all of us
different out reasons we would never come to mind
you do not dear.
So you know that I know it exists I can
try when I do but introduce other people
those cities into my own I'm not black but
is this five years ago was a reason
to
fire.
All of these of our older
students using some of his stuff.
He was to the consist of.
And it always surprises. People there were only a matter
of people so surprised the
world
grew because of his
disability status serving the people who want
to do. Certainly the last one year.
Oh well their affair and track this is of some you
know he was in love and truth who came to a season
and season three years
ago and of interest this young man with the
version
that he said I'm going to I'm going to post
and I heard one of these
from school shoddy work since it was a devil
now and he
just took a long out really good idea but he
did
see the last.
Because it is out of the this is a busy selling job
and this is just a confidence but he had a four time job with
an
track person is you know is also out there.
Even with this is the he's self-sufficient. You know we
have the students who are in the house was reading
one of my other
students one of the good city. This is
this he was another who had
problems with his
academics he was a father because you know we are all you will go all
out
to see series of lessons so heinous act
and
children were not
however good the words of the you or did
he do the go. He
was going off to
school we took on that and we're going to something useful and with us and then
we're this is a new program. He graduated from school because of then and
now being active in the challenge.
He graduated from college and he's using you know these and
to and to. Back to work there were enough programs throughout the school
program dating back to work with us and some
new Another successful one last year was
who salute programs and we had this to go through this is
a college she
says she's already finished House side should she do
the test and she still want to.
Do usually the small can afford to pay her what she's worth
but still the airport is awesome
it's just Friday and we had a we had a
teacher then
said to come on home then need for on some more
shows but issues with the weren't too good for this just a lot
of work that I should get something out of fear.
So she's a deuced. Has a dental
problem and said where you're going to show
them the parents brought on this show.
Well you know that she
was also on our program every summer for her son Prince
of them you know to do this we created quite
a few years to do that
sort of all and then we're sort of using
some. You know for the parents of the principal there and you know
it was right and we have had sort of someone who says.
I have a
student and he was he too soon
to get her very bored
all last. Time issue. Tiny
issues a rite of passage session for you and the song
what is the point of this issue do you want.
Hostile and non-hostile you need to lead and do you
not in the basic you cannot be. You want
to other people to get the. Go on going
somewhere and yes two sisters a little brother and the
mother also building that he can't yet
and he was yet.
Some red shoes on her shoes and
with her shoe This is
of
course you can do. OK Number
one
she number.
So.
Someone now uses it how did she love all of
my good today to a mother. We
stopped her school and college.
Called days and days and all the time I
didn't have a tie
and you know
Todd.
That's
right.
So.
She
left. Work.
When I first heard of do it with.
It was something to
do
I was just trying to be. Gone through
and started just something that's gone through that I started
to realize that you know a lot of the Southern issues that I
guess I'm just a little like me then my good sir and then they couldn't
do the things that really. So
the whole war and to the west of the world to
disagree even being here this is either. We assume that you
should have read books there who
have you know there's a bunch of should know better both from
Conoco. And even though it does some of the video. But this
so many are on
insulin resistance on the
bread was the household your phone
book and the whole import income how did you find in Europe.
And they don't do that no does not undermine the order.
So the notion that a variable and something is doesn't exist in your life or your salon.
How do you know you show
that and then when you do pick it up to do its heart is
not easy and then it puts a
book missile attack or video in there it is done
here good desirable because both of us in this world.
Somebody's already written down or there's nothing new under the
sun. You might want to get a change in to us and was
already here is if you
want but if you don't know they did
exist or you can pull out the images of Diana and
here to say there's a group is a very wealthy nation but
outside forces had
to come inside and didn't find the energy so
the taking out. In the shoes. You know you know the
Home Soon afterwards they can get it for losers
because they don't have the skills that. Or the knowledge of
the loss in the shoes of she.
I
also like to go to prison compared
with. Greed and then ensure the
sin. Population. How do you make sure that
you have children by ninety percent. Well
that is going to leave nothing else for the new you will go here
in Buffalo.
So you know it is a time when I love you love the
city that it was more like the big of these are things and they
go for the they go bad about each
other because knows how to be a young child. The good bad
shot done so you know of the school that will know your
Indian so I can't read or I'm not good it
is you know so and realize that out of it is
to be aware that it is not
embarrassing is not calling you out and once you start to do
something to see below and who need to know that you
can invest in that how do you do to me my first to
do was a fool to myself that I'm this is good
enough the house from the first
duty is just with just
going to have to do it in the go
under I will miss
it and I'm going to
say.
Yeah.
Or one big problem.
That I had my time today don't have today.
And my day.
There are sixty seven houses to get in town hall and
peek and you know the thing of
homosexuality that already. However to date
is down to its present and
it is promoted that now I'm OK but this isn't long.
Where is not. This is not how many see everything
on
most men. What's going on on her family or
a huge daisy here of all of them and.
The girl with a high finger on the lever
on the cell research is different and we have younger than
we used to
be is on the order of the have two five or no shows you know if
you're dating rows of people who have a year old without shoes and mini session.
So you know their pants are younger and the younger you have to
do things a lot quicker. So you have a solid seventy eighty
ninety days of living. You have
then and then your child is gone and we do not know
them and they have their own and then they are put into a
system where this she should
assume these people have homes and these people and I hate these people are not
her principles and you know that so it's
still something to do that is the root of the not
and the school system had
become not just a nice big world
have to design a dangerous element with
the school that teaches and I do respect
my teachers and today I have to say that this is
the teachers of excellence.
Hum. So to just speak like students and I don't want to reach them but this
year the
respect or. You know you shouldn't always something to aspire to you know.
You walk in the streets and I was up with a
teacher and I just don't do my ears OK you
know it and I hope
my teacher talks about this crew thing my.
She feel. And be able or even.
You know this is something you know. Did you just know
that I may not know this and the
problem can be solved by saying there was really so you're
going down here.
Why.
Is
this where the present
situation into the
future outcome because you are you could be in charge in prison you could
be you could you can you prove you know or
get the mother cannot do you
know but yet. She's one of the most intelligent.
And there are a lot of brother not a standstill because.
She could read those words into court for every every
very
consistent and he was really this
book on he was you know he was a that he did do good in school. You know
kills for the reason. You got to do
that and he was I could not read
my mother diseases or to see who was she was
on she was that will do that on seventy eighty when
two children and Sonny really
Jewish and still here says and she.
Very true though not everyone can see jest. Given the right
people with ease and know Iran and that you don't know
that you do the rental and
presidents Harbor. Today among employees
in very good jobs. This is you work really hard. You're out of
stuff and I work in the hut and people you know don't get us and they don't pay enough to do
next going actually not a millions
of qualified or qualified where you are and money will follow you this
is a little cause I read a lot
of follow your push the hunger for the solution to
the SO where a
car decided maybe one child the very best and had it
done and this is
the government you over qualified where you are in the duo's or.
You
know of another eight
hundred.